[Musique]
cette journée internationale du droit
des femmes nous commençons cette
émission par un grand merci merci aux
infirmières aux médecins aux aides
soignantes aux agents d'entretien aide
ménagère elle à domicile à celle qui
tous les jours se plie en quatre pour
soigner leurs patients
c'est pas faux c'est intéressant ce que
vous disiez elle marie be non des
centaines
on s'est alors d'abord écouté oui j'suis
désolé si ce que je dis n'est pas
intéressant non sire de noms mais je
vais dire ce que je dis le mensonge
d'une collégienne qui avait dénoncé
l'attitude du professeur et la
présentation en classe des caricatures
de charlie hebdo
elle affirmait alors avoir participé à
ce court mais quelques semaines plus
tard devant les policiers la jeune fille
revient sur ses aveux
comme tout 30 nitoo je vais vous dire si
vous voulez pas m'entendre je me bat
mais c'est pour vous d'accord la partie
elle a eu dans un premier temps une
position de repli qui consistait à
mentir et ensuite au fur et à mesure des
évidences elle s'est ravisée et elle a
décidé dire la vérité
cette petite fille a été manipulée elle
était manipulé par quelqu'un qui a pris
le témoignage qui ensuite a mis sur
réseaux sociaux c'est tout lier la
puissance des réseaux sociaux et
l'inquiétude qu'on peut avoir c'est que
tout ça se répand comme une traînée de
poudre
les enquêteurs avaient déjà
en exergue le fait qu'effectivement
cette jeune fille n'avait pas participé
aux cours on voit que manifestement il y
aurait je très prudente parce qu'il ya
là aussi une enquête en cours mais il y
aurait une pression familiale très forte
et je crois que nous devons tous tirer
les leçons de ce qui s'est passé
quel est le lien qu'on peut faire entre
un certain nombre de personnes qui ont
des valeurs de gauche et l'islam radical
qui ne paraissent pas être compatibles
et pourtant on voit et notamment à
grenoble que ça existe bien pour c'est
quelque chose qui est absolument
scandaleux au niveau des étudiants qui
m'ont 1 qui ont voulu que je sois exclus
de ce groupe de travail est sûre qui a
tout déclenché qui qui sont blessés mal
à l'aise dès qu'on lève confronte à des
arguments qui sont pas ce qu'ils ont
l'habitude d'entendre
et qui donc un peu cela la formule de
caroline fourest ce qu'ils gagnent c'est
cette culture de l'annulation quand on
dit qu'une seule culture
c'est cette culture de l'annulation aux
états unis qui vise à mener des
campagnes diffamatoires contre quelqu'un
à partir d'un propos que l'on sort de
son contexte que l'on détourne et
souvent que l'on exagère leurs
confidences sont était explosive
l'interview du couple très attendu a bel
et bien tourné hier au règlement de
comptes
le guardian line dépendantes le daily
mail tous prennent le parti de souligner
une meghan markle faible j'ai voulu me
tuer en lettres immenses 1 sur la page
d'accueil de ce site
pendant les mois où j'étais enceinte
pendant toute cette période il ya eu
beaucoup de discussions et des
inquiétudes quant à savoir à quel point
la peau de mon fils serait foncé à la
naissance
c'est très malsain de rejouer le rôle de
diana ou de vouloir le réinventer
jusqu'à porter un bijou de diana à
porter un bijou absolu ma pourquoi êtes
vous parti à cause du manque de soutien
du manque de compréhension
est ce que rob l'aller la reine non je
ne l'appelais vrai j'ai trop de respect
pour elle la reine avait un principe
qu'elle applique toujours never explain
never complain on ne se plaint pas et on
l'a blain
lol enfin il nommé la cj nabeul bon kate
n'a fait pleurer vous rendez compte on
en est là non mais attendez
elle raconte n'importe quoi pour 8
millions de dollars vu du nombre de pays
est bien cet événement médiatique
pourrait rapporter plus de 77 millions
d'euros
le député de l'oise olivier dassault a
perdu la vie hier dans un accident
d'hélicoptère à tour que près de
deauville dans le calvados et l'oeil
d'un imagine la réponse à mr de
buckingham de la reine elizabeth plus
précisément réponse à megan quand on a
un prénom de bagnoles on s'écrase